[Music]
hello happy almost New Year
I'm relation alone and you can tell I'm
just a little bit excited for 2016 to be
over it really was a trash fire of a
year but before we say don't let the
door hit you on your way out 2016 I have
four great smaller original movies out
in limited theaters this weekend and
expanding soon to tell you about right
here on Fandango indie movie guy let's
start with a feel-good movie something
that we all need right about now get in
figures is a great true story very
inspirational and I love the title hem
figures because it refers to a group of
african-american women who are working
at NASA and who were very instrumental
in the space race in the 60s but who
were hidden from public view the figures
that were hidden it also refers to the
math the kind of hidden figures the
calculations that went into sending a
man to space we're doing here we're
putting a human on top of a missile
shooting into space that's never been
done before
I need a mathematician they can look
beyond the numbers math it doesn't yet
exist she can handle any numbers you put
in front of the three real-life women
that this movie focuses on such great
role models especially for young women
and women who are hoping to get into the
STEM subjects Awards watch particularly
for Octavia Spencer who's already
picking up awards nominations for her
role and she Jenelle and taraji are all
brilliant in these roles on any given
day I analyze the phenomena levels for
air displacement friction and velocity
and compute over 10,000 calculations by
hand
yes that women do some things at NASA
mr. Johnson and it's not because we wear
skirts it's because we wear glasses it
does get a little bit heavy-handed when
it comes to the inspirational messages
but it has a great heart and a real
purpose and this is an important film I
think for a lot of us to see so the
inspirational story plus the toe tapping
music of Pharrell Williams is a good
time at the cinema
[Music]
let me ask you if you a white male would
you wish to be an engineer I wouldn't
have to the next film I want to tell you
about is one of my favorites of the year
my favorite film that I saw at the
Cannes Film Festival and it made my top
ten of 2016 it's called Patterson
wearing darling honey okay no not really
my kid needs braces on her teeth my car
needs a transmission job my wife wants
me to take her to Florida but I'm behind
on the mortgage payments my uncle called
from India and he needs money for my
niece's wedding and I got this strange
rash on my back how about you okay this
is directed by Jim Jarmusch and it stars
Adam driver as a bus driver whose name
is Patterson and he lives in Paterson
New Jersey and that is all by design
because that really sums up the movie
it's about the everyday patterns and the
rhythms of our life
he's a bus driver and a poet and this
whole film feels like a poem in a way
when it comes to the rhythm of his life
it shows one week in his life his very
simple life nothing dramatic happens and
that's why I love it it's so simple I
knock off work have a beer at the bar I
look down at the glass
and feel glad
[Music]
this may sound pretentious but if you
just let the simplicity and the beauty
of this film wash over you you just kind
of give in to it and surrender then
you'll have a great time watching
Patterson posture by in Patterson what
is very poetic how if I convinced you on
that one my next film to convince you on
is twentieth-century women you may have
heard about this one already because
it's got an awards watch on it for the
film and also for Annette Bening must
possibly Greta Gerwig for Best
Supporting Actress when you were born I
told you life was very big and unknown
you'd fall in love have passions have
meaning but no it's 1979 and nothing
means in I know you less every day mrs.
set in 1979 and it tells the story of a
single mother played by net Benning who
is trying so desperately to bring up her
son in the right way she wants him to
become a great man the film is directed
by Mike Mills who was the brilliant
brain behind beginners you might have
seen that a couple years ago with you
and McGregor and this has that same kind
of quirky feel men always feel like they
have to fix things for women where
they're not doing anything just be there
so how it's hard for all of you well I'm
not all men
I'm just me Wow yes or not the film
tells truths about being a woman and
being a mother and also growing up and
annette bening is the person who really
sold this film for me because she is at
her best
in this role she's raw she's funny she's
so real and relatable jamie house honest
they never had sex with just the vagina
you have to have sex with the whole
woman that's slightly off topic and
finally my last film to tell you about
is called tony
edmond this is a german film another
favorite from the cannes film festival
and it got a lot of buzz there Awards
watch on this one for Best Foreign
Language Film possibly staying the
ambition cooky here
with my instrument look Lucas - dark
spot he might not have to Muslim
Christian symbol even comes down this is
the story of a father and daughter their
estranged she's a bit of a workaholic
she's very straight-laced she has her
life she likes living it by the book he
loves pranks and loves to mess things up
so he goes to visit her and hopes that
he can shake her out of her very strict
life yes for Tonya channel Kevin will
display a minute he's danced it's funny
I'm gonna use the word quirky again
because it definitely is touching and
relatable all about family and how we
sometimes push them away when they're
the ones that know us the best and
sometimes we need them the most
it also features one of these funniest
naked scenes of seen in a long time
that's hard to pull off try to seek out
Tony admin directed by Marv and aid as
soon as you can
[Music]
they have it recapping the four films
that you should look out for if they're
not playing near you just break them
down because these are all worth of
watch the very inspirational hidden
figures these simple and beautiful
Paterson the funny and raw 20th century
women and the quirky German film Toni
Edmonds
that's it for today's episode and it's
also my last fandango indie movie guide
for the year i'm not doing another one
until next year which means i'll be back
next week happy new year
bye